yeah
i make this look good
oh great the winter soldier
for a guy named knuckles you are really
bad at punching surrender the compass
you're no match for me i've been
training for this my entire life and i
have no training at all yet here i am
ahead of you that's gotta be
embarrassing
[Music]
my rings
has anyone ever told you you've got
serious anger issues you mock me with
your weak jokes but you know nothing
about me hedgehog well i know you
echidnas have a habit of showing up
uninvited and ruining my life ruining
your life another bad joke i lost
everything because of you
my tribe was on the verge of its
greatest victory the last of the owl
warriors had been located soon long
claude's emerald secrets would be ours
but my father stopped me from joining
the fight he said my moment to honor our
tribe would come but it was not this
moment
those were the last words he spoke to me
i never saw him again
we both lost everything that day
goodbye sonic
sonic are you okay deceiver
no no it wasn't a trip
tails take the compass and get out of
here
[Music]
tails come on wake up
he chose helping the fox over pursuing
the compass of course he did
new friends same pathetic weakness
oh
no no no no okay we're in real trouble
here come on tails i need you to fly us
out here time to wake up
see you kids enjoy the fresh powder